ready miss Kimberly I'm ready hello
rejects it is Greg here with miss
Kimberly Bigsby Kimberly Biggs meet
Kimberly Bigsby is one of my acting
teachers yeah same with school I go to
please I got a Warner Laughlin yeah
Werner Laughlin highly reputable acting
school that's right I'm in one of the
most reputable places in all of Southern
California and she's one of the teachers
there - kiss-ass today I brought her on
the channel because I'm trying to you
know just get as much credit in class as
possible there are girls in the class
that I want you to be able to be like
Greg is so funny Greg is so cool he says
so you talked me up and maybe a couple
of girls would be like maybe Greg is
interesting because they're not thinking
it's so far I I disagree
I've had like one girl Lisa she doesn't
count I try doesn't work yeah there's no
budging there watch the Miss Sloan
trailer starring Jessica Chastain on The
Today Show they release like this 5
minute long trailer which is very long
for a trailer but there is the 5 minute
long trailer you were saying that you're
interested in this I am okay you like
strong females do and we're seeing a lot
more that's so weird I prefer weak puny
females like the the prostitutes in Game
of Thrones those are like my kind of
female once you could just kind of just
throw around
I'm not surprised by that at all wow
really
it's called sarcasm Jesus
lobbying us about foresight but
anticipating your opponent's moves and
devising countermeasures the winner
plots one step ahead of the opposition
plays a trump card
just after they play there's making sure
you surprise them and they don't
surprise you ask you again missus phone
could you please describe the nature of
your work on the advice of counsel I
respectfully decline to answer your
question based on my rights under the
Fifth Amendment when you're not taking
the oath to confirming details those
words in that order or all you're gonna
say
this would be a whole lot easier if I
could just shout fit they want you
behind bars
you make one statement you correct one
nefarious allegation that's it you waive
your right to the fifth and you're
compelled to answer everything they're
taking you to the woodshed in front of
the national press they're gonna rile
you so bad they make Gandhi want to cut
their tongues out did you arrange for
benefits such as travel luxury
accommodations and sports tickets to be
furnished to members of Congress at the
behest of your clients did you arrange
for benefits such as travel luxury
accommodations okay when I take the
stand oh he's intimidated she's strong
you think they would choose a more
appropriate venue turns out the
Nationals at a home game cherub just
hearing this Sloan please raise your
right hand
do you solemnly swear that you will tell
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth under pains and penalties
of perjury
not a driver I can but I don't well you
got further than me I didn't even have a
license
she's a lesbian to be honest I suck at
it because she 16 fails my instructor
told me I was reckless I lacked due care
and attention knew that in there I had a
career in politics ooh you were employed
by Col Kravitz and Waterman LLP for a
10-year period between 2006 and 2016
before moving on her 11 year period
excuse me there are 11 years between
2006 and 2016 she's not predictable she
aims to surprise she'll share things
with her team but she won't share
everything she'll have a plan for
certain people but they won't know until
they're dropped right into the middle of
it there's always something else going
on there is just attached
what was the nature of your work with
cold Kravitz Waterman LLP we're not
connecting with the female motor the gun
lobby wants us avoid guns
tools of the female is this the
reputation I've garnered gold-medalist
an ethical LUMO I don't remember you
carry ever good my position solidified
somewhere between Columbine and
Charleston any headcase felon or
terrorist can buy an assault rifle from
a gun show the internet or his buddy at
the bowl-o-rama without so much as an ID
yeah Wow counsel I must respectfully
decline to answer your question based on
my rights under the Fifth Amendment what
do you know about the gun lobby suppose
the Brady Campaign I know they're going
to lose because a total budget is less
than what the gun lobby pays to get
their shoeshine the Brady Campaign wants
you to leave the fight to her done
control you're going to fence out of our
office when it's over you can choose
from any of the DC but he mounts lining
up for your signature within the remit
of this hearing to establish whether I
must respectfully decline to answer your
question based on my rights under the
you're fighting the richest group on the
hill work on behalf of causes I believe
and that's why I sleep at night
simply wing this bonfire duty to the
cause Oscar goes to Wow
just a good Shasta how is intense that
was really intense I was like kind of
uncomfortably there's a lot of
information in there that was a huge
cast by the way John let go Alison Pill
mark Strong in there there's Sam
Waterson in there yeah that was a that
was a huge cat that's not Dylan Baker in
there for like a split second too but I
like about it though is that it's one of
those political thrillers that's very
character-driven at the same time you
know I feel like a lot of times these
political thrillers I think of like
Oliver Stone's yes Oliver Stone I think
like Oliver Stone's political thrillers
those tend to be so like heavy about the
messages and you kind of don't give a
[ __ ] about the characters after a while
because so much about politics instead
and I feel like this is gonna have a
neat blend of politics back with a
character study of this one woman who is
lobbyist in DC so yeah that looks like a
very intriguing kind of plot and it's
like Jessica Chastain just oh is that
she's so powerful
yeah I agree this strong character it
seems like she's clearly going up
against a boys club and the gun lobby is
a huge huge thing you would know more
about than I would well yeah it said
that that's a huge I mean if you're
gonna be a lobbyist and take on any
cause that's gonna be someone to be
recognized for her because it looked
like they were totally trying to crack
her but then at the same time she did
not give an ounce no like breaking in
that no no that's exciting but I like
seeing like the moments before she's in
front of Congress you know why are you
sure like wake up and she just looks
exhausted and she has to like put on
this face and put on this game yeah and
I like that those are the like you need
treating in parts to me where you could
see both of the sides when you see how
she is when she
alone not in front of people and how
she's not the happiest person in the
world but when she's in front of
Congress she has to represent someone
who's incredibly tough yeah which I feel
is like most people in politics probably
just super exhausted but they have to
put on this like armor yeah even enter a
room because all of that power and
confidence sort of has to come from I'm
too emotionally honest that can't be a
politician ever yeah I know I feel like
I'd have to be like made of steel or
build a wall in my heart that moment
like John Lithgow's like yelling at her
like trying to get her to break because
I've scenes people I've seen footage of
people when they're in front of Congress
and he was pleading the fifth
consistently and it's just pissing off
the people like Congress actually seen a
lot going on with everything that's been
going on with all the congressional
trials of like with the banks and
everything and you see these like huge
powerful men that are you know running
these billion-dollar corporations and
they're like sweating and drinking water
and like not even and she's like boom I
really wonder what the main message of
this because I feel like this film's
gonna have some like big overall message
here yeah or me or maybe she's trying to
like make us aware expose something in
like a political thriller format it
feels like it's a little bit of a lesson
on what the hell and I'll be a lobbyist
does anyway cuz like we hear that word
all the time but like even I don't
necessarily I think that it's going to
be a little bit of a lesson a little
informational but then she's gonna go in
and just straight-up kick some ass
because Jessica Chastain does that
Jessica Chastain's an awesome actress
she's she's white she is a powerhouse
actress and like she keeps everything so
close and it just you can't take your
eyes off her and I appreciate that
oh yeah what I love about her is that
you could feel that she internalizes a
lot but chooses not to fully like
express all of that but you can feel it
underneath her the entire time it's
called good acting
all right rejects ever knew the channel
subscribe to dead come accepted that's
how I say it I think Kimberly Biggs me
she is on Instagram it it's Kimberly
Bigsby link in description box and she's
Twitter at Kimberly baby link in
description box as well make sure to
follow her you can look at all our
lovely photos you can stare late at
night three in the morning before you go
to class get weird then you blush and
you're shy in front of her it's all real
and it's not weird
this is honesty there's truth and then
there's weirdness okay I know scared of
photos bird staring focus
don't and like them but then move on